this is artemis launch control with an
update launch director charlie blackwell
thompson has called a scrub
for today history will have to wait just
three minutes into the launch window she
made the call
huge disappointment for those gathered
along the space coast for a glimpse of
artemis won i'm pretty bummed i drove
from minnesota
but i had a backup plan you know we're
at the beach can't complain how
disappointed are you
very
because it's my birthday
this sucks
you travel 10 hours to get here yes 10
hours from alabama so how big a deal is
this for you it's a huge [ __ ] that was
like the biggest rocket ever you've got
artemis t-shirts you must be really into
this project yes we are is it that
excites you about it is it the fact that
it's a woman will go to the moon
absolutely person who's absolutely color
going to the movie absolutely i think
that's huge especially for our children
you know just to see something like that
the vice president kamala harris had
already arrived at kennedy space center
hoping to witness america's first step
towards putting humans back on the moon
but a fuel leak and engine conditioning
issues grounded the spacecraft on launch
pad 39b this is a brand new rocket
it's not going to fly until it's ready
space flight is risky
that's what you do
you buy down that risk
you make it as safe as possible and of
course
that is
the whole reason for this test flight
the artemis program aims to put the
first woman and first person of colour
on the moon by 2025
and establish a permanent base there
from which humans might one day visit
mars
it will be the most consequential launch
in a generation
when it happens
this is about learning about how one day
we can go further and that is the
exciting thing whether or not we use the
moon as a base or what's called a
gateway a sort of a spacecraft that's in
orbit around the moon we can use those
two parts of this artemis mission to
learn much more about what we need to do
this launch has been 10 years in the
making so what's another few days when
you need 8.8 million pounds of thrust to
lift a spacecraft off the ground
everything has to be just right
if it isn't
they'll be wasting billions of dollars
writing a new chapter in space
exploration is a costly business they'll
be hoping this is one small delay and
not one giant setback
david blevins sky news at cape canaveral
florida